president Trump's endorsed candidate
Luther strange lost the Alabama
Republican Senate primary last night but
he lost to the far Trump e'er candidate
Roy Moore is the Trump effect dead
or is it co Pfeffer than ever will
debate then after a vast no doubt
Zuckerberg e'en conspiracy prevented our
interview yesterday with journalist Mary
Lane we'll have her on to explain the
relationship between football protests
and national elections around the world
and finally amber Athey and jacob arey
will join the panel of deplorable z' to
discuss george clooney's terrible poetry
i will be doing a performance woman
drivers in saudi arabia and finally free
money tax reform baby i am michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
this election result is great news it is
a little strange because I'm happy about
the election I'm happy for president
Trump even though president Trump's guy
lost we'll get to why in a bit but the
long and short of it is Trump's guy lost
but sort of and not really background
here is that Luthor strange was
appointed to replace Jeff Sessions in
the US Senate from Alabama after
sessions became the Attorney General so
there was always gonna be a special
election he is technically the incumbent
he's been there since sessions became AG
and so he ran against this guy Roy Moore
Luther Strange was preferred by the
establishment Republicans a conservative
enough guy and then there's Roy Moore
Roy Moore Chief Justice of the Alabama
Supreme Court he's the guy behind the
Ten Commandments monument he had it
built there he was then attacked by the
ACLU the SPLC and Americans United for
the separation of church and state some
organization like that and he was
actually removed from office over this
the court said that they had to remove
the monument he said no no more just
would not do it and so he was removed
then he runs again for election and he
wins so he clearly this guy has a lot of
intestinal fortitude Trump endorsed
strange ostensibly because strange had a
better chance of winning the general
they were worried of a Todd akin sort of
situation that happened in previous
elections where you go with a very
far-right guy in the primary and then he
can't win in the general or he'll fizzle
out or he'll fall into some faux pas
here is the clip of president Trump's
endorsement of Luthor we have to be
loyal in life you know there's something
called loyalty
with these stuff and I might've made a
mistake and I'll be honest I might have
made a mistake because you know here's a
story if Luthor doesn't win they're not
going to say we picked up 25 points in a
very short period of time they're going
to say Donald Trump the President of the
United States
was unable to pull his candidate across
the line it is a terrible terrible
moment for Trump this is total
embarrassment I mean these are bad
people and by the way both good men
both good men and you know what and I
told Luther I have to say this if his
opponent wins I'm gonna be here
campaigning like hell for but I have to
say this and you understand this and
just look at the polls Luther will
definitely win not exactly a resounding
endorsement it's a little bit tepid he
says he'll campaign for the winner
whoever it is he said he might have made
a mistake now President Trump here might
have seen the writing on the wall it
looked like strange was doing better in
the polls or I'm sorry rather more was
doing better in the polls some of
president Trump's most ardent apologists
are saying that this was for DHS that he
knew that more was going to win the
whole time he endorsed president
endorsed strange so that he could make
nice with the establishment with Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan but really he
only did that to get tax reform out of
them you kind of get dizzy when you
think about all of that logic this was
what Bill Mitchell suggested and I that
seems a little far-fetched for me every
once in a while even Dear Leader can
make a bad bet the the one issue in this
primary is that as of June 21st
president Trump had a great record on
these special elections he said it was
five a No depending on how you counted
it's actually probably four four and one
but he had huge wins karen handel beat
democrat golden boy John Assaf in
Georgia
Ralph Norman B Democrat Archie porn
Ellen in South Carolina so this this
race upsets that record a little bit but
I'm not so sure that it actually does
here's Roy Morris victory speech Mr
strange is recognized the one and if you
work with me I've talked to senator Lee
Senator Paul Rand Paul and Jenna food
[Applause]
and various others that are important in
our government together we can make
America great we can support the
president don't let anybody in the press
think that because he supported my
opponent that I do not support him and
support his agenda as long as it's
constitutional as long in advance our
society our culture our country I will
be supportive as long as it's
constitutional but we have to return the
knowledge of God and the Constitution of
the United States to the United States
Congress so if this is a loss for
president Trump's agenda what does
victory look like this is pretty good
Luther's strange if Trump's endorsed
candidate had won he wouldn't have given
his resounding in supportive speeches
that it's really excellent if you're one
like me I like a little bit of a
schizophrenic view of the world I like a
semiotic view of the world a symbolic
one you have guys like Donald Trump you
have the name Trump Trump wins this
election then you have someone like
Luther strange okay and Roy Moore more
Kofi fey more Trump more aggression in
the culture war fighting issues that
people really care about saying
absolutely now we won't remove this
monument of the ten commandments we're
going to stand our ground and defend the
culture that's made our country so great
the the great news about this is it
backs up and cultures thisis ankle to
wrote a book called in Trump We Trust
applause awesome because an has the best
titles the best words doesn't she folks
it's an excellent title and the book is
actually really good it's a it seems a
little bit like a frivolous title the
book makes a good point her entire
thesis is everyone thinks that the
mainstream consensus view is that people
only follow Trump because he has a cult
of personality they love his personality
they love his little jokes and we're all
sort of mindlessly following him because
he amuses us and makes us giggle and it
has nothing to do with issues she says
that isn't true people are following
Trump despite his personality because
he's a fighter he's fighting the culture
more the only personality trait that
really we admire in him is his
intestinal fortitude and really it's
about these issues he's talking to
issues that neither party has talked to
in a long time and that the American
people care about issues like
immigration issues like patriotism
cultural issues and you know we've been
burnt by a lot of so-called conservative
politicians who make nice with the left
and don't pursue our agenda people in
the establishment in DC nan Hayworth was
on former Congresswoman from New York
and we talked about this we know a lot
of those people down there and they hold
the base of the Republican Party in
greater disdain than they do the
Democrats than they do their nominal
opponents on the Democratic side so if
that is the case then that means that
people won't just blindly follow
President Trump off a cliff or follow
him if he pivots to the left or
something they'll hold him accountable
President Trump came down there he said
vote for this guy they said now we're
gonna vote for the other guy because
he's more like the agenda that we
elected you to fulfill really good news
really good news out of there and and
not bad for Trump either I think it's
just fine
that he he endorsed a candidate didn't
work out now he gets to work with a guy
who likes him and the Republican agenda
even more with that maybe I am just
being too hopeful possibly optimistic
here let's bring on our panel of
deplorable z-- we have amber Athey from
The Daily Caller and Jacob Perry from
The Daily wire so many daily
publications in one-word answers it is
Moore's wind good or bad amber good
Jacob good excellent we all agree why do
we even have this panel we're like the
opposite of crossfire you know cross our
is like lamb Iowa us is just like his
trunk Raiders Trump the greatest amber
why did President Trump endorse Lewis
our report that came out of Breitbart
yesterday that said this was all Jared
Kushner's idea and I think the
underlying logic here was that he was
trying to play nice with Mitch McConnell
after all of his attacks on McConnell
but that logic is so backwards because
the solution to McConnell not getting
things passed in the Senate
isn't to turn around and make deals with
him or praise him for his failures its
to elect people that support the Trump
agenda and are going to vote for all
these things that are being pushed by
Trump do you think it was a mistake for
President Trump to endorse Luthor well
with the way that it turned out no
because more won anyway and he still
looks like he played nice to McConnell
so he kind of gets the best of both
worlds here I will say though his
playing nice with McConnell kind of
irritates me Jacob
Moore's defeated opponent Luther Strange
is warning that more will be the new
Todd akin he's referring to these
whacked-out candidates you know who
actually Todd akin he made some very
stupid rhetorical mistakes and it cost
him
it cost Republicans a good seat in the
Senate but you know these guys give the
media anything and they'll pounce and
and jump on a stupid statement is that
the case here is he going to be Todd
akin or has the weakening of the media
even made that logically and politically
unlikely knowing yes I yeah I love bold
statements on this show no and yes
well I say no because Todd incan he was
a relatively unknown person who just
kind of came in on the wave of the Tea
Party movement where a you know he took
advantage of it he really wasn't a tea
party candidate Roy Moore on the other
hand he's he's been in documentaries
he's been interviewed especially with
his time as a judge so he's people know
who he is they're like we like Roy more
and I think that this is really good for
Trump because I do think Roy Moore will
be good for his agenda and I and I agree
with with amber I think our I should say
I agree with you I think that Trump was
just endorsing strange just to go oh
yeah see we're gonna I'm gonna play nice
with McConnell's and if you remember he
said I'm still I didn't have to go to
dinner with strangers family that was
amazing
not exactly a glowing endorsement to say
I came down to to to campaign for you
but I don't want to eat with you funny
as soon as possible amber bill Mitchell
and some of the other very prominent and
loud and vociferous Trump supporters
have said that this was for DHS that
President Trump with he didn't really
want Luthor to win he was trying to work
against him a little bit he was just
trying to get tax reform does that hold
water or are we reading way too much
into this I think that's a little bit
too far into it I think this is more
about listening to his son-in-law and
he's done other things at the bequest of
Jared Kushner that didn't quite pan out
either firing Comey for example so I
think 40 chesses is a little bit too far
and especially considering a lot of
trumps aides to go to try to help
strange he wouldn't have put this much
time and effort into trying to get
strange elected if this were just a
secret kind of chess move to actually
get more its I think they're really
going a little too far with that with
that guess and giving Trump maybe a bit
too much credit and speaking of the
family speaking of Jared Kushner I look
around the president's inner circle
right now and I don't see a whole lot of
conservative Republicans a lot of those
people ban and Gorka have been pushed
out they're not there anymore but for
some reason Jared Kushner still hanging
around
is there a worry that President Trump
will be pulled to the left by these non
conservative voices or will he get the
message from last night's election I
think there's definitely a concern
especially when you look at these
reports that say general Kelley is
hiding reports from President Trump
specifically the ones from conservative
outlets that are criticizing some of the
things like working with the Democrats
on daca and these moves to the left that
he's been getting from Kushner and and
Kelly without Bannon and Korca so I
think that's definitely a concern and if
Trump doesn't know that the conservative
base is rallying against him on these
issues he can't correct himself and do
you think also will go around with you
and Jacob do you think that Ann Coulter
is right is Trump's base focused on the
issues more than his personality would
they leave him if he doesn't do what
they want yeah my parents are proud
Trump supporters and my mom I'm actually
read what Ann Coulter had to say about
that and she said she just summed up
exactly how I feel about Trump in one
sentence it's never been about his
personality it's always been about the
issues that he talks about and so she
feels like the personality is something
that she can deal with as long as he's
getting his agenda through so I think
Coulter has hit the nail on the head
Jakub I think it's I think it's half and
half I think there are fifty percent of
Republicans who supported his agenda and
those people are start will go along
with Ann Coulter but I do think there is
sort of a cult of personality that
follows him along we definitely see that
with his more hardcore supporters so I
think it's a 50/50 thing you'll see 50
state with him no matter what and then
another 50 percent that'll leave because
they were about this I think you're 50
percent right because I do agree there's
obviously a personality component here
but the personality component is the the
courage and the fortitude in the face of
these massive left-wing institutions
that are opposing him well I think we're
all slack-jawed that he's been able to
stay on the bowl so long you know as it
keeps trying to buck him off but but all
right we have to move on from dear
leader but I do I do hope that Ann
Coulter's theory is correct and and also
to that point you know I remember I one
time I was talking to Mitch Daniels when
he was governor of Indiana and I asked
how are you such a good governor he was
best governor in the country and he said
well I I treat my citizens and my
constituents like they're adults and
most politicians treat them like they're
children
I think the constituents of this country
the citizens of this country are adults
were not just mesmerised by glitzy
colors and a lot of the elite
commentators and analysts and
politicians on this issue they think
that it's a nation of dummies it's not a
nation of dummies they're adults they
know they know about their own
citizenship they know about their own
country and you ought to give them a
little credit sometimes okay but there
is one guy who's a dummy and we
shouldn't give him any credit and that
is George Clooney this this is too good
he has written a poem in support of the
in great football players who are
disrespecting their country and because
I loved it so much I
we'll perform a portion of that poem for
you right now we are we ready can we get
some snaps Marshall I guess thank you I
pray for my country I pray that we can
find more that unites us than divides us
I pray that our nation's leaders want to
do the same and it's like ten more
praise me IDI Yad I pray I pray and when
I pray I kneel wow wow wow
not quite Wordsworth not John Keats that
George Clooney amber which is worse the
poetic diction or the political
philosophy I'm gonna pull a Jacob here
and say both alright I will knock you
for it because you're absolutely right
yes I think this is actually published
in The Daily Beast and they had this big
exclusive banner they were so excited
that George Clooney had written this
poem for them which just shows how silly
they are too but the poem is so bad it
reminds you of something that you would
write in elementary school like an
acrostic poem and I kind of feel bad for
his wife Amal because she's supposedly
this brilliant human human rights lawyer
and I feel like Clooney's kind of like
her pet dog that she just passed on the
head is like Oh George you know we we
all have written bad poetry I don't know
about you amber but young men angsty
young artistic men sometimes you write a
little poetry you read good poetry and
then you think I can do that and then
you write in your all as you can't
nevertheless I don't I don't think I've
ever read any poetry of a
twelve-year-old
that's quite so silly and frivolous as
this mainly because it totally
misrepresents the point he's trying to
draw a parallel between taking the knee
and praying to God for unity that is
explicitly not what taking the knee here
is about a Colin Kaepernick who started
the whole gesture said he's taking his
knee because of the oppression of blacks
in the United States the alleged police
brutality the widespread alleged
epidemic of racist cops shooting
unarmed innocent black suspects and he's
disrespecting the country for that he's
saying the country is innately
inherently racist and oppressive it has
nothing to do with praying it isn't
praying to God and even here when you
kneel down that's supposed to be the
sign of respect
oh you can kneel to God but when you're
talking to about a country you stand you
stand at attention and you put your hand
over your heart the symbol of respect
and the symbol of disrespect are totally
inverted but Cluny I don't know that
he's doing it on purpose I think he just
doesn't quite get it because someone
didn't write his lines for him
Jacob or George Clooney and the
Hollywood establishment he represents
just cynical Democrat hacks or do they
actually think that their random
smattering of words and phrases
constitute some coherent political point
I think they're just bitter they're
bitter that they lost and by the way
isn't George Clooney an atheist it seems
like he promotes atheism in every movie
he's ever starred in you know it's
interesting I did look that up I think
he says he's a he says he's a Catholic
he was raised Catholic and then he also
said though whatever anyone believes is
fine as long as it doesn't hurt anybody
so I don't know he's probably just as
confused as we are that could be I
honestly think they're just bitter and
it's just like the new American Horror
Story the new season of that the cult
where they're making Trump supporters
look like they're cultist and that
they're they're sociopaths you want to
who want to devour everyone it's just it
it's just more bitterness from the same
old left-wing Hollywood elite all right
well we have a lot more to get to we
have to talk about the most feminist
advancement a very long time women can
now drive in Saudi Arabia we have to
talk about tax reform and finally we'll
get a very interesting perspective on
football protests and national politics
from this is the only place I've ever
heard this perspective from Mary Lane a
journalist Wall Street Journal
previously new york times AP author but
you can't get any of that you can't get
any of that unless you go to the Daily
wire calm right now and subscribe we
thank all of the current subscribers
they let us keep our lights on
we're now we have a better earpiece for
me today that isn't falling out thanks
to the extra handful of subscribers we
got yesterday so if you go over there
right now it's ten bucks a month 100
dollars a year what do you get well you
get no ads on the website you get my
show you get the Andrew Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show yeah I know I
know who cares who cares right
well hold on a second you get this -
that's right now I have your attention
you get the leftist tears tumbler you
can't get it anywhere else you can't buy
in a store you can't buy it online the
only way that you can get the perfect
vessel the most beautiful vessel ever
made for carrying left as tears is to
subscribe to the daily wire right now
you can obviously we've been bottling
since this morning the George Clooney
vintage this is limited edition but he's
right around the corner here in Beverly
Hills so we're able to get it right at
the source
it's biodynamic its farm-to-table its
organic non-gmo not gluten free go over
thicker right now daily wire.com we'll
be right back
the Saudi royal family has announced
that by royal decree women will now be
allowed to drive beginning next June
Jacob the last conservative bastion is
being wiped away by the forces of
modernity is this the end of the right I
don't know about the right but it's
definitely a definitely a breakdown of
Islamic rule over women and I honestly
think that this everyone is praising
this like it's some sort it's some sort
of breakthrough hello Saudi Arabia still
violates women's rights all around they
still have to go out with their burgers
and the in their hijabs they can't be
seen without without a male companion I
mean this is that's just common sense
exactly that's not well you bring up a
good point Jacob there are some things
that Saudi women still can't do they
cannot marry divorce travel open a bank
account get a job or have elective
surgery without permission from male
guardian or vote they cannot mix freely
with men they cannot appear in public
without wearing a full-length black
Abhaya
they cannot conduct certain business
without a male sponsor they cannot
retain custody of their children and
divorce
they cannot apply for a national ID or
passport without the permission of a
male guardian they cannot eat at
restaurants that don't have a separate
family section they cannot testify
equally in court the testimony of one
man equals that of two women and they
cannot receive an equal inheritance so
just a handful of things that they can't
quite do amber why don't the [ __ ] hats
go and protest over there they would be
jailed and probably murdered I stopped
making a case for Saudi or no I'm
kidding but in amber that is the real
question American feminists are
complaining because of a mythical wage
gap which has been disputed and
dispelled even by Barack Obama's Bureau
of Labor Statistics so why all the angst
over here well these feminists
completely leave the Islamic world in
Saudi Arabia in particular
off the hook you're exactly right and
the problem is if they went over there
to protest those types of things it
would be tantamount to admitting that
the US isn't as oppressive as they make
it out to be I actually read an article
in Cosmo which is basically the bane of
my existence yesterday but the article
was about this new word called heap
eating and it's about it's called heap
eating so repeating but was he in the
and this is when apparently men take
women's ideas in the workplace and
repeat them and then get credit you know
that's so that's so funny amber because
I was reading an article the other day
in Cosmo at this little magazine and I
discovered a new word the word is called
heap eating which is apparently when men
just repeat whatever women say and pass
it off as their own idea I like this
idea we keep eating it's the new
mansplaining yeah but it just shows how
silly modern feminism is in the United
States that they're worried about
made-up things like he keep eating and
mansplaining while women in Saudi Arabia
just got the right to drive and still
lack so many other rights and many of
these feminist organizations are in bed
with people like Linda Sarsour who
openly call for Sharia law and she had
so for them to talk about wanting to you
know free women it's just so
hypocritical while they ignore the
plight of women in the Middle East and
if and they you know you make the good
point that if they went over to Saudi
Arabia they'd be arrested and murdered
or jailed or something but they would
never go over to Saudi Arabia because
that would dispute and do away with
their intersectional hierarchy of
victimhood at which the straight white
Western male sits at the top and he is
the oppressor and everyone else is the
oppressed this began I was reading some
account of this I don't remember who
wrote the essay
this began though in oh I'm sorry this
was in Jonathan Raj's book about free
speech he said that this began with the
sallman Rushdie affair that was the
moment when we had to deal with our own
principles Salman Rushdie wrote The
Satanic Verses he had a fatwa put on his
head the Islamic world
tried to murder him forest is still
trying to murder him for it and the
Western world which previously believed
in liberal values and free speech we
buckled we said well it wasn't nice of
us or a nice of Salman Rushdie to upset
the people over in the Muslim world and
hey they have a culture and we have a
culture and we have free speech and they
throw people off buildings but you know
who are we to judge who are we to judge
and its really paternalistic ironically
it's much more paternalistic for these
[ __ ] hat clad women in America to say
we're going to fight for even more money
in the United States more money than men
make but oh those women in Saudi Arabia
they're different they're just a
different sort of breed and well good
luck ladies
absolutely absurd now we have to talk
about money forget about all that stuff
Donald Trump is pushing finally tax
reform he has a four point plan it's
very exciting to simplify the tax code
to lower middle class taxes to cut the
corporate tax rate the marginal tax rate
and the effective tax rate and to
repatriate trillions of dollars in
profits that are currently being stored
overseas because we have the highest
corporate tax rate in the world
people dispute that by the way they say
our corporate tax rates over thirty nine
percent and they say well that's the
marginal rate but that's not the actual
rate that businesses pay when they pay
their income taxes or their business
taxes rather but we still have the
highest effective corporate tax rate in
the world as well by some estimates it's
twenty percent by some it's up to twenty
six percent so it's true it's not as
high as thirty nine but it's still the
highest in the world if we lowered it it
would boost the economy amber there is
one issue in this tax plan which is the
president Trump wants to raise the rate
on high-income earners is this a good
idea and why does he want to do it no I
don't think it's a good idea and I'll
get to that in a second I think he wants
to do this because it's part of his
again trying to misguidedly reach across
the aisle and make a deal with Democrats
and I think here's why it's so misguided
first of all there are already so many
Democrats who support a lot of the tax
reform efforts including lowering the
corporate tax rate including lowering
taxes on middle-class citizens
for Trump to then give away the fact
that he's also going to raise taxes on
the upper-class
is the opposite of the art of the deal
that's giving Democrats every basically
everywhere we throw away the leverage
exactly that's yeah that's exactly the
points the same exact thing that he did
with daca I think raising the tax on the
highest people or the highest income
bracket is definitely a little bit
backwards considering those people
already shoulder most of the burden of
taxes in this country to begin with you
would certainly agree that they don't
pay their fair share they pay much more
than their fair share they pay actually
like all of the taxes in the country but
it isn't oh yeah that's the Democratic
argument of course these people also
take a lot of their money and put it
into businesses and hiring people for
jobs and investing in various startups
and small businesses but yeah not their
fair they don't pay their fair share I
remember in college they had an Occupy
movement in New Haven and so we went
there there to occupy occupy one day and
there was some whiny guy yelling about
finance or Wall Street or something and
we asked him we said well what does Wall
Street do he said well the yeah they
invest money said okay how do they
invest money so well they invest money
and companies say okay so what are those
companies do well they they invest that
money into capital or labor yeah okay
and what does that do
well yeah grows companies and creates
jobs we took him through the entire
because people have this idea that
corporations they think that these high
net worth individuals are going in their
backyard and burying money if they put
the money in the bank or if they put the
money in the market or they invest in
companies it's in the economy it's it's
creating capital for the economy and
it's it's spurring growth but don't ask
the left to give you too many points on
economics all they do is they buy that
Piketty book you know the new Communist
Manifesto capital and they don't read it
they just put it on their their shelves
in virtue signal Jakub it's it is
upsetting this this
trying to raise the rate on the highest
quintile of earners who already pay most
of the taxes anyway but are we even
gonna get tax reform is this a way to
bring on people like Susan Collins or
are the RINO Republicans going to shut
it down and prevent even that
legislative victory you know I honestly
not sure I think that if the Republicans
don't bring this forward this only again
makes Trump look good and if the
anti-trump Republicans if they want to
consume a Trump look bad they need to
actually pass some of his law so he can
sign it and then they can blame him if
it causes a problem but instead they
won't even let his stuff come up
including tax reform and so I I'm not
sure if this will saw like Obamacare
repeal and replace will or is but I but
I have a feeling that some of the RINO
Republicans like Susan Collins and Lisa
Murkowski I don't let Rand Paul off the
hook I'm so sorry talked about this
yesterday I am so sick and tired of
letting Rand Paul off the hook by
pretending that he has principles thanks
a lot for your principles that killed
Obamacare great principles buddy thank
you for joining what a moral upright guy
well in Rand Paul's case though the
Republicans you know how they always say
don't let the perfect get in the way of
the good the Republicans promised
perfect in the case of Obamacare they
didn't promise good they promised
perfect so well repeal Obamacare I don't
care I don't care what they promised I
don't care what Rand Paul wants I don't
care how he looks at himself in the
mirror repeal Obamacare and give me okay
well then just repeal it stop offering
all these ridiculous other laws just
repeal it yeah okay I mean we're delving
a little bit into Obamacare here we're
talking about a sixth of the economy I
don't think that the onus here is for
the entire US Senate in the White House
to do what Rand Paul wants to do I think
he's got to deal in reality and I don't
think I don't think it's the Republican
Party in the White House who is not
dealing in reality here I think it's the
people who are letting the perfect get
in the way of the good but they promised
perfect who cares when you let the
perfect get away they're good you get
the worst is what really happens okay
amber one last question
The Washington Post ran a headline the
middle class doesn't want
Scot now this is objectively false I
want a tax cut four Pinocchios give me
money let me keep my actually don't give
me money let me keep my money I want to
give less of my money to you so this
does get to an actual point the washing
brush doesn't know that they're making
this point but they do get to this point
our economic issues really at the
forefront of America's mind are we
really just concerned about tax cuts or
is the cultural battle where Americans
are really pouring in their heart and
their soul and their political efforts I
think it's a little bit of both I think
tax cuts are really important to
Americans as a poor journalist I will
lead the charge on that I definitely
want to keep more of my money I know
most a lot of people especially
blue-collar workers voted for Trump
because they were hoping to see more
money in their paychecks economics is
routinely listed as the number one
concern for voters in elections so
that's still really important that being
said I think Trump is actually the one
who has made people care more about
these cultural issues because he's been
raising them so often I think this
entire week the only thing that I've
heard about are the NFL National Anthem
protests and that's on cable news and
conservative circles and everywhere
that's like the number-one issue right
now and then of course there's the issue
of immigration so it's a little bit of
both and I think the culture the culture
wars are coming directly out of Trump's
rhetoric and the issues that he's
choosing to push and it's because he can
win on a lot of these issues but isn't
that the point he can win on these
issues so is it Trump who's pushing them
is it Trump who is the source of the
this cultural concern in the country or
is he just the vessel
did he just realize that this is what
the Americans care about right now and
is he the symptom rather than the cause
yeah it's a good question and it's
probably again a little bit of both not
so it sound like too much of a cop-out
to sound like Jacob all right I'm sorry
go ahead amber no it's fine I was just
saying people definitely care about the
issues but I don't think that those were
necessarily things that they were voting
on until they became raised in the
election by Trump absolutely right okay
panel thank you for being here amber
Athey from The Daily
Jakub arey from the daily wire me from
my daily show thank you both great panel
today that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show come back on Thursday that's
our last show is tomorrow get your
mailbag questions in and we will see you
then
[Music]
you
[Music]